mark and Miley here you are together so
how did this collaboration about was it
kind of team Miley calling team mark
ronson or how did this how did this
happen there's Mark Ronson's stalking
Miley Cyrus before you hear that I don't
remember it exactly this way so you want
to tell your story that you made up I
saw Miley on television singing on the
Saturday Night Live 40th anniversary I
knew she could sing and everything but I
started seeing Paul Simon 50 ways to
leave your lover in a way that just I
was just transfixed so I got a number I
don't know if it was legal oh no and I
said I decided taxi and I just said hey
if you ever want to make some music you
know and then you know four days went by
nothing this is the part I don't
remember I feel like I must have sent an
emoji at least the broken heart emojis
great to have cousin people Texas that
they love the song you just put the
broken heart among yes yeah I think you
would text me back like after a few
weeks and just write like what's up
probably late night like 4:00 in the
morning maybe yeah and that went on for
four years I believe my family we've
always talked about timing
and trusting the universe and always
trusting that you know timing that
everything is always works out when it
should and I think we've said it
multiple times to each other in the
studio that anytime before this would
have not been right and any time after
this would have been too far away I
think it's perfect timing with this song
at the time that it's out in the world
that's why we made the video that we
made and the visuals that we've created
it's just such a timely song for me and
my personal life and what's going on in
the world so I wouldn't have it any
other way than sitting with you right
now right here this this song only came
because of where we were and how we met
and and I agree
you
[Music]